Welcome back.
Now we're going to use an object diagram
to clarify how text fields interact with
delegates using the UI text
field delegate protocol.
We'll start with the view controller.
Which of course has outlets to
the four views and here are our views.
Up here our colorizer are and
the emoji delegates.
You can see that each of the
corresponding UI text field view objects
has an outlet pointing to a delegate.
These objects can be delegates because
they implement the UI text field
delegate protocol.
This third text field has the view
controller as its delegate.
So the view controller also needs
to implement the UI text field
delegate protocol.
So why would we want to use
a view controller as a delegate?
Because the view controller's role
in the architecture is to manage all
of the views.
The behavior of the third text
field is connected to a label.
The label is updated with the character
count whenever the text in
the text field changes.
Now I want to walk through the method
indication so we can clarify how
the delegate pattern is used to keep
the character count label up to date.
So if we were to trace
the user's actions,
the user's going to tap on the third
text field tap a key on the keyboard and
then the number is immediately updated.
Now let's step through that sequence
of events again in our diagram.
The user taps the keyboard.
The text field realizes
that the text will change.
The text field invokes the method
should change characters in range.
All of these methods
happen behind the scenes.
The text field invokes the method.
Should change characters in range.
The view controller
receives that invocation.
So it updates the label.
And it returns true.
If we zoom in on
the ViewController.swift file,
we can see the code for
some of these steps.
We won't be able to find these
first three steps in our code.
Those are happening behind the scenes.
The first step we can
see is number four,
when the invocation comes
in from the text field.
Here is step five,
where the variable new text is being
set to the characters we just typed.
Here's step six, where the text
of the label is being set.
And here's step seven, return true.
Notice again that you don't get to see
where the UI text field delegate method
invocations begin.
We just implement the protocol and
handle the indications as they come in.
Now let's take a quick look
at the other two delegates.